so
thank you for having me thank you for
inviting me nicole leah
chris this has been an amazing
conference i've been amazed
by the location and all of the guests
and all the talks we've been having so
thank you um so i'm patrick hammond as
jen
mentioned you can get me on twitter
there um i'm here to talk to you today
about css and the critical path now what
does that mean
i don't really know i hope you'll know
what that means by the end of this talk
so as jen mentioned it's
a talk it's really a bit of a ruse i'm
here at css conf
i'm actually here not really to talk to
you about css but more
about performance and the importance but
importantly how css is intertwined and
tightly coupled with
our critical path the path from which a
browser takes surrender to our screen
so have you if you haven't guessed
already i work for the guardian
it's a national uk newspaper
which is now a international media
organization we have
offices in new york australia and london
um
and i work on the core web team now
which we're helping to make the next
generation of the guardian website we've
spent the last 18 months completely
re-engineering from scratch the guardian
website
it used to be before horrible large java
monolithic application
and we're now moving to a mobile first
responsive website um
as brad frost once create coined the
phrase planting the responsive seed it's
very hard
for large organizations to shift to
responsive so
actually we kind of took tiptoed along
the way we
first replace our mdot subdomain with a
responsive site which
is going to become the platform the
basis to take eventually hopefully this
summer
we're going to completely remove the old
site and have one single platform
and so today i'm going to talk to you
about some of the lessons
i've learned building this
last month we broke a record at the
guardian we had 100 million unique
users within the first month that makes
us now one of the largest new
organizations in the world
but on the flip side of that those 100
million
are being made up of accessing our site
from over 6
000 different devices and our current
platform the old site that's there for
10 years
wasn't designed it can't cater for this
array of devices
and it's just not acceptable what we are
serving to these devices
and we had to do something about that
but more importantly
the site is extremely slow
so here you'll see on on the left-hand
side our old site and the right-hand
side our new
site and the difference in the rendering
speed between the two of them
just so you have what you think yourself
so within three seconds we've finished
painting and rendering and fully
complete loading of the whole site
whilst we're still chugging along on the
old site
and that that's a median average it
takes 12 seconds to paint and finish
loading of our website to the user now i
just don't think
that's acceptable and i hope you guys
don't too but you know it's not just
us at the guardian to see this problem
use the low time expectations
us as users our expectation of how fast
a website takes a render
is reducing you know from 2000 it was
nine seconds all the way until 2012
it's just two seconds that your users
expect your website to load in
and again the problem's not just ours
this is for taken from hp
archive.org a great google initiative
that they indexed
data from the top 200 000 websites and i
ran this query
uh on bigqueries last month to ask ask
it hey what is the speed index
the speed index is a metric that um is
in milliseconds how fast your site takes
to fully render
and the top ten thousand websites the
median average is nine thousand
milliseconds right nine seconds
whereas we know that our users want it
to load in under two
can you see where i'm going here with
this so but the guardian
you know how we have to relate this back
to our business so when we were starting
out on the new project
we surveyed 3 000 of our users and asked
them about 17
core kpis product indicators of which
one of them was speed
and unsurprisingly to me those users
rated speed as a feature the second
most important thing only after easy
defined content
you'd hope on a news website that the
content is easy to find
although that did surprise the business
though but it was great for me because
that allowed us a leverage to
really drill into them that we need to
make this new platform fast
and it's not just that as well there's
been a lot of hci research recently that
has gone into the fact of the cognitive
levels of us as users how
how we perceive speed on machines
this is taken from illicit uh high
performance browser networking he works
on the
google make the web faster team it's a i
strongly advise you read that book but
here it says that for for us as users
for feel that a machine
is actually functioning and working any
action you perform must
respond within a thousand milliseconds
one thousand milliseconds and that's not
just
you can't just relate that to websites i
could relate that at home i'm sitting on
the couch i'm watching tv
i change the tv channel i want that tv
that tv needs to respond within a
thousand milliseconds for me to deem
the machine working and after 10 seconds
my mental subconscious just moves on and
that task is completely abandoned
um so tim kaldak's been talking about
this a lot recently
so now we know that a thousand
milliseconds is what we're trying to
reach
our website should render within a
thousand milliseconds
what if we were to set a budget to
enforce that in our development workflow
every new feature every new page we make
has to
hit that budget so that's exactly what
we did at the guardian we've set
ourselves a budget of ensuring that all
pages render within a thousand
milliseconds
no longer we can think in in seconds as
web developers we really need to start
thinking in milliseconds
so let's dive a little bit deeper into
this for us to be able to understand
how we can paint within a thousand
milliseconds we need to understand
what's going on in behind the scenes how
the browser
goes from that and you clicking on that
link to being able to paint on the
screen
but also knowing how the browser works
makes us as web developers make
better decisions when we build our web
applications
so hopefully you've all seen one of
these before this is a um
a waterfall chart taken from webpagetest
there's a segment explaining
the network each bit of the network's
made up of the dns lookup so converting
the nicetheguardian.com string
into an ip address we then can go the
computer can use that ip address to go
make a tcp
socket connection a freeway handshake
and then finally
i can make the actual ht request i can
say hey give me index.html
and when the server deals with that it
responds and finally we can download the
content
and so all of that has to happen um
before we can even start creating a dom
but our phys out of our thousand
millisecond barrier
600 milliseconds of that on average is
already taken up but this is on a free
average 3g mobile connection
600 of that is already taken up by
latency
we've heard this before latency is the
biggest killer to performance
and especially on mobile so every
network you request you make
you're incurring this 600 milliseconds
and so that leaves off with only 400
milliseconds to really paint to the
screen
and now you start to think of how
important it is to
rendering so this is being very
simplified but this is
what the critical rendering pass is this
is what your browser has to go through
to be able to paint to the screen so
let's look a bit deeper in that so i
ask for my index page i perform the
network on it incur the 600 milliseconds
once i've got the html fortunately i can
start parsing the html and creating a
dom structure
now one of the greatest things about the
html spec is that a dom
construction and html parsing can happen
incrementally so we don't have to wait
for the whole file to be downloaded we
can actually start creating the dom
as the packets come in and this is an
amazing feature so
i'm sitting there i've packets come in
i'm constructing a dom
and boom my browser hits a script or a
link element it has to stop
it can't construct the dom anymore it
has to stop blocking it has to go back
and perform the networking to go and get
that css file
so i download the css file to create the
css object model
now the css object model and the dom
together create a render tree it's
another tree-like structure that has all
of the information about the nodes on
your page from the
top left to bottom right um but
the due to the cascading nature of css
we can't parse the
css incrementally like we did with the
html file because of the cascade so
styles at the top of the page might be
overwritten further down
in a media career or something like that
so and that would actually constantly
start
painting flashing to the screen and
causing reflows so you know actually be
a negative user experience so
we have to wait for the whole css file
to be downloaded before we can
construct the the css object model
and then our lovely friend info
javascript
now if we find the script element
javascript
blocks dom construction because of that
that great feature document.write
javascript can alter the dom and so
because of that the dom
can't continue to pass but javascript is
tightly coupled with css because
the c it has to block and wait for the
css object model to be created
because um what is javascript was to
query a style on a node
and this is why the age old best
practice of putting javascript to the
bottom or even more importantly
declaring it as async you're you're
making a promise with the browser saying
i know this javascript is not going to
do any
anything dodgy you you can just take it
off the critical path
um but it's really interesting this
relationship is intertwined
tightly coupled and i asked this in in
an interview quite a lot to people i'm
interviewing
so what yo so yeah yeah i put javascript
to the bottom of the page why do you put
javascript
oh because it blocks why does it block
and they never know it's surprising how
many people
don't actually know what is the actual
reason why javascript blocks our browser
rendering so we've done the good thing
we've taken javascript off the only
thing we're left with is the css object
model we need
that and so finally we can then perform
layout and paint
and you can see here how this is all
traditional websites look like this
we've got our html we then download our
css and our javascript if we
make the javascript asynchronous take it
off the critical path
now we've already shaved off a lot of
milliseconds there to be able to paint
so we know we have to get the css down
as soon
as possible it should be the only thing
on your critical path and in my opinion
it is
the critical path
but how can we optimize our css for this
start to answer ask that question what
actually is
your critical css and especially on a
responsive website you know that concept
of above the fold no longer exists
something that is above the fold on the
mobile might not be above the fold on
your desktop
so here's the average guard in article
page is my critical css the sharing
widget or the popular content or the
comments
none of this it's only the article
the user came there to read the news
that is the only critical css that you
require to paint to that screen
and it should be the only thing so we
take that one step further at the
guardian that you know we actually
ajax in and progressively enhance all
the rest of the initial payload actually
only has the html
the html for the article in it this is
our non-cr
our critical css versus our non-critical
and so angelina just up before me and
started to allude to this fact of
so we now know what our critical css is
but what if we were to inline that css
into the head of the document knowing
what we just
we just learned from browser rendering
then the browser has
everything it needs to be able to create
the render tree within
one http request everything
we don't need to wait that incur that
600 milliseconds again to go and
download
the rest of the css file all of our
styles the critical ones for above the
full content are delivered
in the first payload now i know it's
very controversial
but that's exactly what we've started to
do at the guardian
so we've got the style element at the
top this goes against everything we've
been taught
as good web developers you know
separation of concerns
styles and css behavior and javascript
files and completely separate
but if you want your page to paint
within
a thousand milliseconds this is what you
have to do
so if you go to the guardian beta site
right now you'll find this disgustingly
odd
ugly blob of javascript to the top
compressed into 14k
so if you've got a full tcp connection
window open
you'll have enough information within
the first packet
for the browser to render to the screen
so that's enough of that what is that
actually like to the user
so the top doesn't have any in line the
bottom does
we've rendered in 600 milliseconds there
and
we've basically nearly finished painting
and the one without hasn't even started
but the um for the for the observant
ones
of you in the in the audience would have
noticed that i still have to load the
rest of them right i've got my critical
styles but i need to
be able to load the rest of them in and
so we're now at the bottom of the page
we have to async in the javascript and
then
create a style element and inject it
into the head
therefore completely taking the rest of
those files off the critical path
even more observant in the audience we
started thinking about that
hang on a second if you do async in the
rest of your global styles isn't that
going to cause a massive
ugly reflow or repaint once those new
styles come in
and you're in fact correct that's
exactly what happens
and once we first implemented this a
couple a week later
um the creative director of the guardian
came walking in and said what the hell
is this ugly flash on my website
and he was right you know this it wasn't
acceptable that the users was yes we
managed to
if we optimize it well enough you know
they wouldn't see it but if they started
scrolling soon enough they'd see that
horrible
paint instantly so the only way to get
around this is that we obviously have to
manage that somehow we have to cache it
and so we looked to local storage to act
as a cache that
what if we could once we've asynched all
of that css in
we could then cache it in the user's
local storage and the next time around
we have all of the information within
the first request to be able to paint to
the screen
avoiding any uh any flash of on-site
content
so first we we ask if the the browser's
modern enough the bbc's cut the message
test you know does it have
xml hp object does it have event
listener if not no
just use a normal normal world link
um but is there already stars in local
storage yes
great let's paint if not
do they have local space storage space
now this is an interesting one we found
that a large percentage
and especially iphone users have a quota
exceeded
um already on their on their local
storage
if so request it with ajax cache it in
the local storage
and then paint again and then on the
next time around we can instantly just
go straight to instant painting with all
of our styles
not making a single request to to a
style sheet
so here we've just uh on to our top back
in the heads
we now check to see if the storage items
are there if it
is inject it into a style node there
instantly
all of the styles within the first http
request
and enough to deliver the news to the
user within a thousand milliseconds
again now down the bottom so we've now
we've done our normal ajaxing
but we now have to store it so here
we're actually
doing a bit of caching validation for
three at the same time here
if they've managed to get into this
block it means that they're either their
style is outdated
or they don't have any so we first loop
through all of the local storage items
to check if they match against our
pattern if they do we clear it
and then load in the new one and store
it again so
we're using an md5 hash here of the file
so every time
we practice consider continuous delivery
we're deploying about four or five times
a day now
and so instantly we can invalidate that
css the old global css and get the new
ones
straight away but what does this mean
um actually again to our users so here
we're using webpagetest here this is
a uk cable connection um
and so before we've got we're still
blocking rendering
waiting for all of our css and our
javascript to download
we async the javascript and then we
inline the css and cache it in local
storage
instantly look at the difference to the
waterfall here we've got a start render
event right there even though we're
asyncing in the rest
the browser doesn't need it because it's
got its inline styles here
we've managed to shave over 500
milliseconds
off our start render event just by
inlining the css
and caching in local storage
breaking our 1000 millisecond barrier so
again if you go and look at the site now
you'll notice that in the style sheet
tab in any inspector you won't
see any physical files downloaded but if
you go and check the local storage
you've got your css right there
interestingly we also do the same with
our fonts
to avoid any flash of unstyled text with
the font loading
now as well as having fast pages this
also creates a much
more resilient system a system in which
i'm traveling on the train a friend of
mine shares a link to a cool article on
twitter i click on it
but boom i go into a tunnel now
fortunately my
my mobile had enough networking to
perform the network request that first
html request
but but normally i'd go into the tunnel
and then it would find the css file and
try and make the downloading for that
but you can't
because you're in the tunnel and that's
that big white blank screen that we're
all so familiar about
with this technique we've created a
system
resilient to failure that i only need to
make that one request and i have all of
the information
google to do this google and bing
have also do this you know it's why i
write one of google's search results
pages the fastest page in the world what
they do is actually
more interesting they send down all of
the styles in the first request
and then they put it in local storage
but they set a cookie so that when you
request it again
any other i know all the subsequent
requests after that have already got all
of the styles
we can't actually do that at gardening
because we keep a completely stateless
domain so we don't use any cookies so
that we can cache
our html on
so with all performance techniques you
must
monitor these and optimize and repeat
so to do this i built a grunt task that
in the ci
now i'm monitoring the size of those of
those head files
and so whenever a developer updates the
size of those files i can get alerted to
see if it goes too big because obviously
we don't want to go in the negative
opposite way that the file gets too big
and then we're actually bloating our
pages and slowing them down so
in the ci we monitor these and i now
know the raw and the gzip file size and
it gives me and i can trend this
over time and set and the threshold
alert and knowing when
our assets get too big
again on in pull requests this is a big
code smell to me when someone's adding
something to the head file
you have to ask them is that your
critical css
does that feature really deem to be in
the head
and so monitoring assets like that is
all well and good but actually what are
real users seeing and and
especially across the world so to do
this we use um a tool called speed curve
and this this uses clusters of web page
test instances around the world
and we can um it tracks and trends
analysis for us but
i can filter this by our start render
event or our speed index
and i i instantly know how our page is
performing
over the last two weeks but more
importantly again i can set thresholds
on this
and compare myself against our own
competitor which is our old site or even
our competitors um business competitors
in the wild
if you have tools like this it's really
really important that you then
facili spread this around the department
so now every week
all of our everyone in our department
from our project managers to our
designers
get this report telling us how fast the
website is and if we've broken
anything and this is really really
important making everyone in the team
accountable for performance is the only
way that you can
ensure that you maintain that and it's
been really interesting having project
managers come up to us and say hey what
happened last week why have we slowed
down
by 100 milliseconds and it's great to
see them actually caring about that
getting everyone involved now
i've talked a lot about our technique
but what um or are some of the
alternatives out there
google page speed module for apache or
genex
has a feature to be able to inline on
the fly
um so it actually actually render the
page work out what the inline styles are
and inject them into your page so this
is at a proxy level so you can sit
sit this nginx proxy in front of your
systems now
there's reasons why i i love page speed
it does a lot of good optimizations but
the specific inlining css feature
there's some reasons why i don't like it
i like have to
have a lot more fine uh granular control
over going in the head or not
on css and grunt uncss tasks by adios
money
um this you can pass it in multiple
files on your website and it will
actually
work out what is the css required for
this
nicole earlier on mentioned that she did
all this great work to optimize the css
file but it was actually bootstrap in
the end that was
that weighing up 50 with this as a as a
post optimization
her worries was she doesn't want to um
delete summer bootstrap because it would
make upgrading in the future if you have
this as a post optimization
you can get it to strip out your css
file and you just have a new minified
one that only
has the bits of bootstrap in it that you
are using across your core templates
basket.js again by osmani this uses
exactly the same pattern of
using local storage as a cache
management and validation layer
but all of this seems like a hack we
shouldn't be having to do this as dead
developers
take these extreme um things of breaking
everything that we've learned to be able
to to get that last couple of
milliseconds out of our performance
fortunately there's been a lot of
thinking around this area recently
so http 2 which is the http the
underlying transfer
protocol layer of the web we're actually
currently in 1.1 that was spec in 1997.
it's now 2014 and we finally got
a new point a major version this is
actually
near to finishing of the standard it
will be finished by the end of this year
but
how does this relate back to what i've
i've mentioned is there's a great
feature in it called server push so
acp 2 the biggest benefit to us and as
we know
latency is the biggest killer how do we
reduce those round trips and the latency
is that
you can have multiple bi-directional
messages on the same
tcp connection so for my html file my
css file and my javascript file
i don't have to open up three different
tcp connections i can send them
all down concurrently down the same
socket
but we've got this traditional flow
right we ask for the html file
the server gives it back your browser
then parses the html finds the css file
and then goes and requests it again
but as web developers we know that the
browser is about to then request the css
file
or your core javascript file so knowing
those decisions
what if we could push them down with the
initial http request
so this is a new feature called server
push that completely um
i forget the need of any of our
techniques here because i can say hey
browser i'm
when it when you ask for the initial
html file you can say hey and here's all
of
my other core assets i know you're going
to need them and let the browser
do the caching validation or work out if
it needs them or not
service workers now this to me hb2 and
service worker are
among one of the most important features
coming to the standards that we're gonna
have within these next five to ten years
service worker is being worked on by
alice russell um from the chrome team
and jake archibald and actually
interestingly really developing the
whole spec out in the open on github i
strongly advise you to go and check it
out but so service worker is
a request handling with a persistent
cache so you can create a worker level
that handles all of the requests within
your browser
and deem whether or not you want to go
back to network or return something from
a cache so basically it's app cache
on steroids or the better app cache and
so
here's the traditional module again i
request my css file
and then we go off to the server to go
and get it
but what if the service worker already
had one in its cache
or you know we were using local storage
abusing local storage for this pattern
now we actually have a new cache object
in css and service workers that have the
native new promises spec built in it
said
right if i've got that in my cache
object return it
and so now we don't have to ever even
talk to the server
again having all of the information the
css to be able to paint
within 1000 milliseconds
so just to summarize i've actually gone
really really fast
um here are some of the things that i've
learned along the way
and that i hope you do take away from
this
please have a think about inlining your
critical css
and deferring all non-critical assets
the your critical rendering path is the
most
important thing to getting your content
in front of your users
and anything you put in front of it is
going to block them and as we know that
600
round millisecond round trip for every
request is just bolting onto your
millisecond budget
where possible always cash aggressively
and maybe in local storage or hopefully
in the future and service worker
and set a performance budget on your
sites
but once you've got that you need to
always measure
optimize and repeat you know our
websites get slow on a day by day
basis as we add features to them you
need to constantly be measuring that
or thinking about when i add a new
feature do we actually need this feature
or how can i better optimize this
feature make it fast before we include
it or
is this feature going to detriment our
loading or the performance of other
features
but most importantly feature performance
is a requirement
it's not a feature
you can't retrofit it you can't oh don't
worry the ops team are going to handle
it
we all as web developers must be
worrying about this
and as i said before the more you make
this information available to the rest
of your business
the more the rest of your business will
start caring
thank you
you